hello there how are you it's nice to see
you again I know that I've been gone for
a while but I can assure you that I'm
not dead I've just kind of been feeling
slightly uninspired but now I'm feeling
really creative thanks to the new guitar
strings that I have recently a quiet
so let's make a video today I'm gonna
make you a video right now okay oh it's
me Charlie what's up okay so today I'm
going to tell you some really really
really exciting news but before I do
that I'm gonna tell you some slightly
less exciting news so we're gonna build
up throughout the course of the video
okay so get your excitement hats on and
get prepared for okay in just under one
week my age will be turning from
seventeen to eighteen which here in the
UK I don't know how it is where you live
but here in the UK once you turn 18
you're officially a grown up so in less
than a week I will be turning from a
child to a grown-up yeah to be perfectly
honest with you I'm not really like too
excited or scared about turning 18 like
my only real hope for turning into a
grown-up is that on the day of my
birthday I'll wake up with like a fully
grown beard but you know we can all
dream I guess the traditional way of
celebrating an 18th birthday here in the
UK is to go out to a pub and have your
first point or 10:00 and get plastered
but I don't drink so I've got really
nothing like to look forward to
apart from the thing I'm about to tell
you about which I've talked about before
the really exciting thing that I'm gonna
tell you about now and it is really
exciting okay the official date of
celebration for my birth is Wednesday
the 1st of October but I've decided did
you catch any of that because I said I'm
really really fast the official the
official date for the official I don't I
can't even say it now this is so strange
ok just I'm gonna be 18 on the 1st of
October Wednesday the 1st of October ok
what I have decided to do to build up
and to count down to the time when I
will turn 18 is to have the most epic
blog TV show in the history of the
Internet please don't leave just because
I mentioned blog TV I can promise you
that the Pockett in you show that I'm
gonna have is going to be seen so
insanely worth it's so worth it and you
are going to love every 7 hours of it
yes
7 ok jeez I told you it was really
exciting I'm just getting old I'm
getting 4
now okay okay on Tuesday the 30th of
September I'm going to be having a blog
TV show which will start at 5:00 p.m.
GMT and will finish at 12:00 p.m. GMT
and will last seven hours and will
finish at midnight
at the time when I will become a
grown-up but what is even more exciting
than the blog TV show itself is what is
going to be happening during that blog
TV show I am going to be doing challenge
Charlie three and I'm going to be
shaving all of my hair off for charity
can you believe it are you stunned you
should be because I I can't quite
believe I'm saying this myself but
that's what's gonna happen what I've
done is I've set up an account on Just
Giving calm which is just giving calm
/blog TV birthday and I want you guys to
sponsor me to shave all my hair off live
on the internet and I'm gonna film it as
well and put it on YouTube and every
single penny that I raise is going to go
directly to cancer research UK I'm due
to the way that just giving calm works
no money goes through me so you have to
worry about any of that every single
penny like I said goes directly to the
charity and it's a it's a great charity
I'm sure you all know about Cancer
Research UK already but if you don't
I'll put some links in the sidebar which
will tell you more about it however yes
there is more stuff to get excited about
I'm going to be doing the entire 7 hour
long blog TV show in the presence of mr.
Alex day or so known as nerimon you
might have heard of him he's quite big
on the youtubes me and Alex have come to
an agreement that if we manage to raise
three thousand pounds or more during the
course of the show then Alex stay will
be shaving his hair off as well it's
it's all coming off on Tuesday I can
assure you so hopefully you're kind of
excited now I would I would enjoy if you
came along to the show if you can't
that's okay but if you can then come for
God's sake um because it's gonna be epic
I just told you what's gonna happen so
there is one slight hiccup though which
is that seven hours apparently it's
quite a long amount of time so far I've
only managed to plan about an hour and a
half's worth of content and so what I'd
like you guys to do is suggest things
for us to do during the show they can be
anything you want post a comment or a
video response or whatever you want to
do send me an email I don't I don't know
don't care just tell me what to do in
the show otherwise it won't be as
because I've made out to me which will
be scary so please give me suggestions
of what stuff we're gonna be doing in
the show thank you the show is gonna be
happening at blog tv.com ford slash
people forward slash charlie is so cool
like it's gonna be starting at 7:00 p.m.
gmt which is 12 p.m. EST i got it wrong
it's 2 p.m. EST don't come at 12:00 that
will make everything really complicated
i don't know what that is in PST or
whatever but you can work it out I'm
sure and it's gonna last for seven hours
and it's gonna be amazing
so please please come goodbye